the creepy porcelain doll Annabelle is
unleashed again with a fresh set of
spine-chilling demons and Annabelle
comes home it's a third Annabelle movie
and is actually both a sequel and a
prequel and with Annabelle having
appeared in six out of seven of the
conjuring universes movies so far things
are getting pretty complicated for the
demonic dolls timeline yep UK movie
lovers I'm John and in this video I'm
explaining the full chronological
timeline for Annabelle in the country
movie franchise plus I'll be discussing
how the new movie reveals a surprising
connection to the conjuring Tsar the big
bad the demon nun VALIC spoilers ahead
for Annabelle's appearances in the
country universe movies the timeline for
Annabelle begins with Annabelle creation
which establishes the origins of the
demonic doll within the country universe
the movie begins in 1946 with doll maker
Samuel Mullins finishing his work on an
exclusive set of a hundred porcelain
dolls one day as the family returns from
church their car breaks down and while
Samuels fixing it the Mullins daughter
Annabelle also known as Bea is
tragically killed by a speeding car
you're going to want to remember be
because she reappears many years later
in Annabelle comes home I think that's
the wrong house there is no Annabelle
here this is after their daughter's
death the Mullens are so devastated that
they pray for a way to see Bea again
they're contacted by a malevolent demon
masquerading as a spirit of their dead
daughter who asked for permission to
move into one of Samuels porcelain dolls
a manifestation of B returns to the
Mullins household however when Esther
realizes it's not really her daughter
the demon attacks her in an attempt to
take possession of her soul the church
steps in and manages to contain the evil
spirit in the doll the dolls then sealed
in B's closet which is lined with pages
from the Holy Bible and blessed by a
priest for safety this keeps the demon
locked away until 1958 when the Mullins
takes sister Charlotte and a group of
orphans into their home one of the
orphans Janice is mysteriously lured
into B's old bedroom where she finds a
key that opens B's closet this releases
the spirit of the Annabel demon which
terrorizes Janice and the other
girls over the following nights by the
way similar events occur many years
later in Annabelle comes home when
another girl breaks the house rules at
the Warrens this time when she finds a
key and accidentally releases the demon
doll from the box which is keeping her
contained once Annabelle is unleashed in
Annabelle creation we start to see her
true demonic form as the demon attempts
to take Janice's soul he helped me
Janis escaped this encounter but is
disabled further and days later when
she's taken outside Annabelle seems to
summon another evil spirit of a nun this
time who pushes Janis into a barn so the
demon in the form of B can attack the
young girl B vomits into Janice's mouth
now possessing her the entity that
helped Annabelle could very well be the
conjuring famous nun Ballack who starred
in her own spin-off the nun Annabelle's
ability to call on other evil spirits is
revealed by Lorraine Warren in Annabelle
comes home it's the doll it's a beacon
for other spirits the Annabelle demon
who's now inside Janus begins a
murderous rampage starting by killing
Samuel Mullins and when Janice's friend
realizes what's going on she tries to
destroy the doll by throwing it down the
well this fails with the doll
reappearing moments later inside the
farmhouse and it's the first
chronological example in the Kundra
universe of how it seems to be almost
impossible to destroy the doll once it's
controlled by the demon in later films
Annabelle is dumped numerous times in
the trash only to reappear later back
inside the building in both the
conjuring and Annabelle comes home the
Warrens explained that trying to destroy
the Annabelle doll only makes things
worse and that the genie is better kept
in the bottle the only way to stop the
Annabelle demon is to contain it again
in Annabelle creation this only happens
when sister Charlotte manages to shove
Janice and the Annabelle doll into Bea's
old closet jamming it shut it's only a
temporary measure though and when the
police come to investigate they discover
that Janice has dug her way out through
a closet wall and escaped leaving behind
only the porcelain doll which has taken
away by the police
Janice ends
Orphanage and when the Higgins family
arrived to adopt her she reveals she now
goes by the name of the demon that
secretly hiding inside her I wanna
introduce you to mr. and mrs. Higgins
and you must be Annabel Annabel what a
lovely name
over the next 12 years Annabelle Higgins
aka Janice grows up and joins a cult
called the disciples of the RAM the
Annabelle doll then reappears in 1970
when John form gives his wife Mia the
doll to add to her collection that same
year an adult Annabelle Higgins returns
to the home of her adoptive parents and
together with her boyfriend brutally
kills them the crazed pair then break
into Mia and John's house next door
where Annabelle discovers Mia's doll
collection the possessed Annabelle
Higgins tells me a witch is echoed
eerily later in Annabelle comes home by
the bloodied woman who suddenly appears
to Lorraine inside the Warrens car thank
you Tom
during the forms home invasion Annabelle
kills herself while holding a porcelain
doll and a trickle of her blood runs
into the dolls eye this transfers the
demon out of Annabelle's human body back
into the doll where it will next begin
to terrorize the form family after
continued attacks by the doll Mia and
John contact father Perez who takes
Annabelle away to his church where he
hopes the sacred place will weaken the
demon the doll is able to conjure the
form of Annabelle Higgins who attacks
the priest and the Annabelle doll ends
up again in Mia's apartment to demand
her soul in return for sparing her baby
to save Mia her friend Evelyn
sacrifices her own soul by falling out
the window together with the Annabelle
doll moments later the doll disappears
reappearing six months later in a store
where a mother buys it as a gift for her
daughter Debbie this leads us into the
prologue of the conjuring were ed and
Lorraine Warren investigate the
Annabelle case for the very first time
Debbie and her roommates explained to
the warrens that their porcelain doll
has been mysteriously moving around the
apartment to try and figure out what was
going on the young nurses took it to a
medium and the Annabelle diamond then
tricked them by pretending to be the
ghost of a seven-year-old girl called
Annabelle Higgins who died in the apart
the demon said it wanted to be friends
with them as it was lonely so the
roommates gave it permission to move
into the doll at which point the demon
started to terrorize them damaging their
belongings and scrawling miss me all
over the walls and ceilings and those
messages reappear later in Annabelle
comes home at this point the country and
Annabelle comes home converged with the
opening scene of Annabelle comes home
reminding us how demonic possession
works within the country universe it was
a big mistake acknowledging this doll
through that the inhuman spirit tricked
you you gave it permission to infest
your lives so the doll was never
possessed no no it was used as a conduit
his moved around to give the impression
of possession demonic spirits don't
possess the things they possess people
the Annabelle comes home prologues then
fills in a small narrative gap from the
conjuring showing the Warrens telling
the nurses they'll take the Annabelle
doll away to keep it somewhere safe but
before the doll reaches the relative
security at the Warrens artifact room ed
and Lorraine have to drive it back home
and the doll immediately creates trouble
causing their car to break down outside
a summit tree while EDD is fixing the
car Annabelle summons an array of
spirits one of which pushes ad into the
path of an out-of-control truck in a
callback to how B was run over in
Annabelle creation after the Higgins car
also broke down ed and Lorraine do get
the doll back to their artifact room
where they lock it away in a cabinet
made of Church glass and have it blessed
by a priest like in Annabelle creation
this contains the evil for now until the
main events of Annabelle comes home
which take place one year later now this
is where the timeline gets a little
tricky because during this intervening
year the main events of the first
country movie actually takes place the
Warrens investigation of the parenting
in Harrisville Rhode Island takes place
in 1971 and during that time the evil
spirit Bathsheba goes to the warrens
house and lets Annabelle loose and they
both attack the Warrens daughter Judy
by the way if you're wondering why Judy
looks different in the country compared
to Annabelle comes home it's because the
producers decided to recast Judy Warren
with actress mechanic grace in the third
Annabelle movie so after the Perrin
haunting in the conjuring the main
events of Anna
Bell comes home take place in this new
Annabel movie babysitter Mary Ellen's
friend Daniela accidentally lets the
Annabelle doll out of her glass cabinet
after touching pretty much everything in
the Warrens artifact room Annabelle who
as Lorraine explained as a beacon for
other spirits then unleashes a horde of
new demons and monsters on duty Mary
Ellen and Daniella who were home alone
in this movie the Annabelle demon
specifically targets Judi in her soul
first Annabelle manifests as be the
Mullins daughter from Annabelle creation
she then also appears as Annabelle
Higgins from the first Annabelle movie
before emerging as a demon itself when
Judi attempts to return the Annabelle
doll to the glass cabinets the demon
starts to suck her soul from her body
Judi manages to grab a crucifix and
place it on the demons head which
weakens it until all three girls are
able to lock the Annabelle doll back in
the glass cabinet at this point all of
the other demonic entities that
Annabelle summoned disappear
shortly after Annabelle comes home on
the conjuring timeline is the curse of
La Llorona which takes place in 1973 the
Annabelle doll appears in flashback when
father Peres mentions his encounter with
the demon after Anna comes to him for
help on how to deal with the weeping
woman and Annabelle appears briefly at
the very end of the country to when Ed
Warren puts the Crooked Man zoetrope on
the Shelf near the doll in the artifact
room The Crooked Man has a spin-off
movie in development which has been
delayed due to the popularity of the nun
so it'll be interesting to see if
Annabelle factors into that future story
in any way any of these new villains
from Annabelle comes home could return
in the next country movie or even their
own spin-offs and it's been rumored that
the conjuring 3 may include demonic
werewolves which means we could see the
black Shack from Annabelle comes home
return very soon so would you like to
see any of the new demons in Annabelle
comes home get their own movie and do
you think Annabelle should return in the
country universe let me know in the
comments below next tap left to find out
all about the deleted ending to the nun
that you never got to see or tap right
for another video you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time you pick a movie lovers